du 24 mars la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
se fait sentir depuis des mois chez
trajectoire emploi qui offre des
services d'orientation et d'aide à
l'emploi à Lévis on reçoit probablement
plus lors de Dove d'emploi qu'on a de
candidats présentement dans la région
métropolitaine de Québec le taux de
chômage a atteint un creux à 1,9 % en
février un record le fonction publique
l'université mais c'est pas le seul
raisons l'économie est assez diversifier
si vous faites un tour des parcs
industriels il y a beaucoup de beaucoup
d'industries il y a pas juste un grand
employeur c'est bien diversifié la
région alto chômage le plus faible au
Canada avec un taux national de 5%
d'années où la région de Québec
les tourments le moins élevé au Canada
aussi la région de Québec une des
raisons ou le vieillissement de
papillation est assez avancé les
croissants et population active et
inférieur ou quoi une conjon toujours
favorable aux travailleurs c'est
l'employeur qui passait un entrevue
plutôt que l'employé présentement il y a
des employeurs qui présentement vont
être davantage enclin à embaucher des
gens qui auraient peut-être pas embauché
le 5 6 7 ans à la Chambre de commerce le
président n'est pas surpris par le
chômage sous les deux pour cent alors
les chiffres aujourd'hui tout le monde
les avait venus ça fait des mois et des
années que l'impact est senti à Québec
il explique que la rareté la main
d'oeuvre nuit au fonctionnement de
plusieurs entreprises qui doivent
parfois refuser des contrats par manque
de bras ce qui les pousse à faire preuve
de créativité c'est beaucoup beaucoup de
solutions qui s'additionnent souvent les
gens passent à avoir régler cette
immigration oui et l'innovation et
l'intelligence artificielle et en
donnant un meilleur conseil au travail
l'adaptation aux nouvelles réalités du
marché est essentielle parce que selon
les analystes la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre sévira encore plusieurs années
ici Flavie Sauvageot Radio-Canada Québec